okay guys an interesting theory about
Ultron has been making the rounds making
us wonder whether the villain of
Avengers age of Ultron could come back
and seek revenge in a future Marvel
Cinematic Universe installment well
people are pointing to this shot from
spider-man homecoming when Peter is
locked in the government storage
warehouse remember he tosses aside
Ultron's helmet and clearly the time was
like a little Easter Egg to the dozens
of Ultron clones that he made of himself
and he passes consciousness among an age
of Ultron
but the way remember we knew which of
those robots Ultron was at any given
moment was by the glowing red eyes and
this Ultron helmet has those glowing red
eyes so could this be Ultron did he
survive visions final strike at the end
of that movie somehow did he was there
one other robot that he like popped back
into now it wouldn't be the craziest
thing for Marvel to bring back an old
villain of course Red Skull just made a
surprise comeback and infinite war after
all and an Ultron that has been locked
away in solitude for years that'd be way
angrier impasse basically the tyrant he
is in the comics more so than the Tony
Stark invoked one in age of Ultron the
robbery California version I don't know
do you think Ultron could make his
return adventures for to help in the
fight against Thanos are you guys
interested in seeing Ultron again and if
so how should the MCU
bring him back into the narrow not as a
major character if they did bring him
back in I think it'd be fun for like in
the background of real small kind of way
which is very silly he's like on a beach
vacation there's something I don't know
it I don't think it was a successful
enough interpretation of the character
to be curious about how would he react
to these events mmm what have you
plugged his head into like a ship and
you had it like there's like a talking
nav like I don't know if you wanna I
mean James Spader I have no idea what
his priorities are so I don't know if he
wants to do that role but serious answer
to your question I don't need more I got
enough it was already weird enough to
see those mannerisms come through and
like a metallic body like for him to
design he designed eyebrows for himself
so that he could emot-- more
so people could understand them anyways
I'm fine with no more but it would be
interesting to see more villains like
maybe abomination showing up because if
you saw Hulk and abomination teaming up
that would be very scary like that would
be pretty scary to see him like copy to
the fight and then you just have him
snapped out or killed or something that
way you don't have to worry about him
yeah I think you're touching an
interesting thing where I think both of
us are pretty into the idea that hasn't
really happened but in comic books no
one's really dead and it can be fun too
especially the villains especially
successful villains to be able to bring
them back
I mean actually we did just hear about
Black Panther 2 without what anything
might have villains return in that and
it's just like part of that comic
nature's of the fact that like you can't
kill evil and and it'll always find you
when you when you're weak and
susceptible to it again and I think
that's fun but then we're also both like
oh all Tron does all OH hmm he got his
own movie it's ok if he didn't if claw
showed up I'd be more actually down for
that that'd be kind of interesting even
though he'd be really not the most
helpful person in that fight I would be
more interested in seeing someone like
that not Zemo nevermind I like but
there's there's some other choices and I
just don't know if like the amount of
work you'd have to do to explain why
he's still around would pay off in a
really cool way but what do I know I
don't think you would need to do that
much work like they didn't do they had
barely aligned for red scold and people
I was like ok no his is almost the
easiest one hopped into a toaster I need
more old I I don't I don't think we've
had enough I think it was a kind of a
missed opportunity in age of Ultron I
think James Spader did fine I think that
movie you know it wasn't perfect but I
really enjoyed it but I think there's so
much more you can do with this character
he can be so much more maniacal he just
fell victim unfortunately too many of
the Marvel characters and that they
couldn't be the ultimate villain because
Marvel really has been one long 18 movie
movie he leading up to oh yeah think
about this so if he was still alive how
scary would it be if you were able to
get a hold of the nanotech that Tony now
has in his armor and if you wanted to do
some Fox Marvel like rumor mill stuff
like we know we saw like I think you did
a video on err you've mentioned that
Deadpool and cables a little time Turner
thing looks a lot like this little time
to saw in Avengers 4 and cable adult
with a techno-organic virus so maybe you
could kind of seep that into the MC it's
a very scary concept of like nanites
that are used at that kind of are can be
contracted like a virus and can alter
you into like part of Ultron or it could
just be that you're being evil robot but
basically you lose a sense of self and
that could be a very cool threat to have
in a future movie if Ultron came back
that would be a very cool way to do
instead of building bodies he literally
just converts people's like I can't blow
up the earth so I could just convert all
of you into me and it's like egos whole
motivation but planets sides but make a
little bit smaller yeah that could be
something fun that they could do but
it's a fun element in Marvel Comics and
it's an important message about
chlamydia you think about this theory do
you want it to be true or or you like
many people you had enough you're ready
to move on to a new villain but yeah as
always remember to subscribe to new rock
stars for all of our deeper theories
about the MCU things that may be a
little BS but still fun to talk about
and think about cool thanks everybody